oh the gun right my name is param ah
welcome back to Silent Hill 1 we're
going out this town is [ __ ] I would be
like shut [ __ ] Cheryl I'm out of here
like
yeah we're good Cheryl have a gun I
guess I'll check that alley back again
what [ __ ] alley finish Street okay
we'll just make a no not that alley [ __ ]
that alley that alley was horrible
I'm not good eyes hello anyone here I'm
not afraid to kill you you know I got to
make sure I know the controls okay yep
I'm ready to kill people
I'm not afraid to kill you you know what
okay I got it oh whoa whoa these [ __ ]
streets are huge oh [ __ ] me
no it's coming back alright alright come
at me bro [ __ ] is your penis in me I
don't want to be pregnant in by that
thing right in your deck you have now a
vajayjay oh I can smell your fear I can
smell your fear [ __ ]
right-handed Napa that's just how I roll
alright let's check the map okay we need
to make a left in this street I think
yeah alright I can do this
don't worry breast I just wish I knew
how much ammo I add Wow
ah we got to go to this stupid out of
the way [ __ ] this alleyway
okay Cheryl no another 101 not another
one
hey you got to be ready but oh no oh no
I don't tell anything can I chop him Wow
obviously not I just wait do I have ammo
reload 15 rounds I'm pretty sure I use
those already well [ __ ] me okay
thank you a game I'm out of here come on
Raph
oh shut up shut up shut up okay I'm
running I'm running [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this [ __ ] this second
dogs going did I make it
oh well I think Kevin's quicksave on
that [ __ ] safe state I gotta know the
key key show okay [ __ ] it I don't know
them right now oh [ __ ] that I've never
been this happy to see a [ __ ] mess
motor shed all right no problemo
[ __ ] dogs out of nowhere out ow
Thursday camera angle can you keep up
I hate this angle does it make me
[ __ ] nauseous
Wow are you trying to start in my way
now how it is
oh no sir so what is this oh thank God
thank God thank God thank God all right
I don't have to [ __ ] chop them yes
take them no I'll just [ __ ] leave
them come on get real quit
reload we are good to go ladies and bras
right just breasts that sexist okay
brothers are girls too I'm sorry I'm a
guy I just got a mixed up what am I
doing here
am I supposed to look for clothes that
it hey don't be discouraged to school
isn't the Sherrill sketch book I would
guess then yeah she's at the school okay
well this will just [ __ ] go there
what happened
no don't crash on me please some crash
on me I'll be gentle oh it didn't crash
good um oh that's so far are you kidding
me oh geez
this is gonna be trouble [ __ ] a steel
pipe it's bit bad and what is this a
sketch book cover this picture is how
the hell is that you head hills at me oh
I didn't see the text come on let me see
the text the first picture that Cheryl
drew in the sketchbook that I gave her
oh [ __ ]
all right we'll just have to go back uh
we came from here as yeah I need I
forgot I need to take a hell yeah okay I
got this
yes it we're a little better now we're
almost green I'll take it hey I'm gonna
exit how do i exit shed I use both of
them well 11 new line ladies and
gentlemen 11 you learn
I just want to how I keep running into
everything all right it's a sorry I wait
ah come on please please tell them they
have gone this just please don't tell me
they're still there they're still
[ __ ] them out I'm out of here
senorita fill the Congo let me see you
move like a come from but um yeah [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] you
why don't we gotta chase me another one
over here and then we gotta take a right
I'll take a ride all right yeah no I
don't get it
okay well this [ __ ] go here what is
this
out of my way ladies and gentlemen we
are coming what is this now
come ah this seriously how we breathe
okay there don't don't waste your breath
brah what is this doghouse okay I'm not
going to that [ __ ] dog house what is
this nothing that was it
did we mark the map we don't know where
the dog house is okay let's find the dog
house I don't know which side it is on
how Sarah dog house anywhere ear zero
dog has anyone online street
good Yuri and oh this house looks creepy
oh it's got to be on the other side
yep let's check the other side or it's
farther down these rows aren't huge your
brothers can't deny cuz you can't send a
side of the jungle huh
whenever fight afoot [ __ ] you doggy that
it has shed is protected by doggies all
right come on brah
Bam Bam Bam Bam
oh let's find your twin what is his name
Rufus isn't it
come here Rufus I'll [ __ ] your mother
Edom's it makes sense and it's
disgusting and why I said that
okay hello where's the key oh I guess I
can take it now where does the key go
right the game tell me the key goes to
the house ye acaba I like a bow like a
butt butt-butt-butt buzz all right what
do we got
did I I just do that oh thank god
thank you thank you plant now why am i -
you're so nice I hate you paired what
why would you hand okay
this house is creepy nothing useful over
hey what about this some handgun bullets
I love how they are just scattered
around here doesn't really make sense
but that's his life isn't it all right
give me that
yes thank you all right what else do we
got keep up hello health thank you
I'll take yeah yes yes and let's use it
cuz I'm almost dying yeah yeah um the
refrigerator is empty you didn't even
open it
come on who's making salad here sales
like that there are three logs okay what
about this the keys for eclipse
something is written on the mat hanging
on the wall keys for eclipses and they
mark the territory and I can't go that
Lane I guess or maybe I'm supposed to go
that Lane to go there copy it it to the
map good well we got what we came for
Wow I think I should say actually
so I can't so it's pretty pointless okay
yeah we got Brad go outside in the
darkness [ __ ] I hate this place [ __ ]
this town it's so creepy
goddamn this Amiens I got a break from
it I was happy okay uh seriously you
lose you need to work out bruh what is
up with that
alleyway over there let's first go to
Illinois Elroy is a cool guy I just want
him to fly on my belly because I like my
belly belly bound belly bounce bounce
baby belly bounce I don't even give a
[ __ ] that defying dinosaurs trying to
kill me sir Zilla maybe it's like a time
machine and dinosaurs came back
pterodactyls I think they are called
they are awesome that [ __ ] they are
awesome dinosaur so the game is telling
me I have to go straight [ __ ] you
pterodactyl I killed all your friends
and your dogs I don't know your friends
are not what is this no parking
well [ __ ] that's gonna be probably if I
find a car we're not gonna go in this
creepy [ __ ] either way no thank you
we're gonna go to the circle place I
don't know what's wrong with my face cuz
we just liked okay ah [ __ ] me [ __ ] you
alright done in my way sister are you
kidding me to the right oh come on you
caught me off guard yellow that's
show me at any I hate when I don't know
if they just [ __ ] fly off or not
alright let's just go through here and
go to where the line is
is this off-limits
here we go in here whoa pretty shy
shouldn't be going in here oh hell okay
that's call Oh someone dunked a dog's
head come on that is not right you
should not do that
no sir take it take it still don't
really know the controls night well oh
yes and we need to drink that right away
yes cuz we are thirsty for some health
drink what is this a key stop that's a
key key of wooden man take it
okay what the hell is wood man and who
was playing basketball with dogs heads
they're seriously doing it Ron okay
Joanie let's get out of this [ __ ]
place I guess I drew what you get for
going in places says up more
pterodactyls gonna go ride and check out
the era I just want to be free with my
[ __ ] shut up bird doctor bag taste em
alright still last amazin a what's that
[ __ ] burn Wong
why does he want to kill me somebody
oh great great great great great great
okay okay okay back [ __ ] you oh well
where is a Wow right in my face I told
her I'm beautiful okay I don't shoot the
one that's dead
I don't shoot the air don't shoot the
air bro okay he went off let's check out
this police car
I'll just keyed I found another key
press awesome oh yes we found cheese but
no doors kiev lion okay so we have Q
blank it would and I'm gonna end this
episode here and we'll find the key of
penis in the next episode I can build if
you enjoy this guy alright hey I'm
actually in a computer family that's
right
but scary allosteric
shoot him take the shotgun bro
take the shotgun Thank You taco shut up
you gotta lose it
yo you're a fat [ __ ] Saget coming dad
get it yeah shoot his brain zombie I
don't make me do it
I don't give a [ __ ] ha ha ha